ينضم الينا للحديث في الملف الاوكراني
الزميل عبد القادر درماس مرحبا واهلا بك
عبد القادر عبد القادر كنت في اوكرانيا مع
فريق فرنسا كاتر في مهمه انجاز تقارير
ميدانيه وعدت لنا
بمجموعه من التقارير بالطبع نشكرك على على
العمل على هذه التقارير وعلى كل ذلك وفي
الحديث قلت لي بانك تود ان تركز على
نقطتين ربما لا يتم التركيز عليهما بما
فيه الكفايه اليوم في وسائل الاعلام
اولهما قضيه الاطفال يعني يحكى بان هناك
عدد كبير من الاطفال تم اختطافهم او يتهم
الجانب الاوكراني الجانب الروسي باختطافهم
ما هي قضيه هؤلاء الاطفال ما هو مصيرهم
وما هي المعلومات التي جمعتها حول هذا
الموضوع الموضوع موضوع اختطاف الاطفال او
ما يشارع في اوكرانيا حول اختطاف الاطفال
بيتا بيتا العنوان الرئيسي لمجموعه من
المواقع الاخباريه وحتى مواقع منصه
التواصل الاجتماعي لهذا قررنا كفريق ان
نعمل على الموضوع توجهنا هناك تضارب بين
كيف وموسكو في التسميته كيف تقول ان
القوات الروسيه قامت باختطاف اكثر من 3000
طفل وترحيلهم الى روسيا وتوزيعهم على بعض
الملاجئ لحمايه ورعايه الطفوله وتجنيسهم
في المقابل تقول
الروايه الروسيه انهم قاموا بنقل وترحيب
هؤلاء الاطفال من اجل حمايتهم حتى تتضح
الصوره اكثر مؤخرا وزاره الخارجيه
الاوكرانيه قامت باتهام السلطات الروسيه
بترحيل مجموعه من الاطفال بالفعل عندما
كثفت القوات الروسيه عملياتها العسكريه في
الميدان قامت القوات الروسيه بالتوجه نحو
مراكز حمايه الطفوله من اجل وطلبت منها
ترحيل هؤلاء الاطفال قبل ان تبدا العمليه
العسكريه والقصف المتكرر بالمدفعيه
الثقيله بعض المراكز وافقت بعض المراكز
رفضت يعني بالمناسبه تواصلنا مع مديره
مركز لحمايه الطفوله في مدينه خيسون جنوب
البلاد وقالت انها رفضت الفكره والمبدا
لكنه تم اقالتها واستبدالها بمديره اخرى
مواليه النظام الروسي وبالفعل تم ترحيل
اكثر من 200 طفل من هذا الملجا هناك بعض
العائلات لم يكن لها الخيار بسبب العمليات
العسكريه واستهداف بعض المراكز السكنيه
وافقت على الفور على تسليم اطفالها من اجل
بحجه الترحيلهم وهناك بعض العائلات رفضت
وهنا السلطات الاوكرانيه تستعمل هذه
النقطه بالذات وتسميه بالترحيل القصري
قمنا بالتواصل مع بعض المنظمات غير
الحكوميه منظمه انقاذ اوكرانيا هناك التي
قامت او عملت على هذا الملف منذ اكثر من
سنه وقامت ورفقناهم في عمليه استرجاع اكثر
من 60 طفل عبر الحدود مع دول البلطيق لانه
كان من الصعب جدا غدي
السماح بمرور هؤلاء الاطفال من الحدود
البيلاروسيه او حتى الحدود الروسيه
المشكله الان انه بعض الامهات تنقلوا الى
موسكو وقاموا باسترجاع وترحيل اولادهم لكن
النقطه السوداء في هذا الملف بالذات هي
الاطفال اليتامى الذين ليس لديهم اولياء
الجهات الروسيه ترفض تماما تسليم هؤلاء
الاطفال الى اي لا اي مركز وتقول انه لا
بد من تسليم هؤلاء الاطفال الى اوليائهم
في غياب الاولياء ماذا قام بماذا قامت
القوات الروسيه وخاصه رئيس
عفوا
الذي اقر مرسوم رئاسي
يسمح بتجنيس هؤلاء الاطفال بالجنسيه
الروسيه حصولهم على الجنسيه الروسيه بعد
سته اشهر فقط من وجودهم على الاراضي
الروسيه وتقديم مساعدات ماليه الى الاسر
التي تقوم برعايه والتكفل بهذه بهؤلاء
الاطفال هنا القوات او عفوا السلطات
الاوكرانيه تريد استعمال هذه النقطه
بالذات في الملف الكبير الذي تحضر له منذ
مده والا وهو اتهام القوات الروسيه بجرائم
الحرب لانه حسب القانون الدولي غادي عندما
تقوم بترحيل الطفل وتقدم له الجنسيه كانك
تريد ان تمحي هويته وهذا يدخل في اطار ما
يسمى قانونيا بالاباده الجماعيه الملف
الملف كبير معقد نوعا ما زالت المنظمات
غير الحكوميه
التواصل وبالتنسيق مع بعض الجهات الخارجيه
خاصه مع الباب تقوم بمحاوله استرجاع هذه
هؤلاء الاطفال العمليه لحد الان او طريق
طويل امام هذه الجمعيات لكن سوف نرى كل
هذه التفاصيل غادي في الروبورتاج الذي
نعمل عليه والذي سوف يتم عرضه في 24 فيفري
يعني بعد مرور سنه على الغزو الروسي
لاوكرانيا
بالفعل الموضوع هام جدا
وفقنا انا وفريق ان نقوم بالتواصل مع
مجموعه من الزوجات والجدات والامهات الذين
ما زلنا في معركه يوميه للتواصل مع الطرف
الروسي من اجل على الاقل خبر اخبار على ان
رعاياهم اولادهم عفوا او اولادهم عفوا
وعائلاتهم ما زالوا على قيد الحياه لانهم
الى حد الان لا توجد اي اثباتات على
وجودهم سواء في السجون الروسيه او
البيلاروسيه عندما بدات العمليه العسكريه
في 24 فيفري مجموعه من الاوكرانيه
المدنيين تطوع للعمل مع القوات الاوكرانيه
وللمحاربه والقتال ضد القوات الروسيه
بالطبع تم اعتقال عدد كبير منهم الان
يتجاوز الالاف وتم سجنهم في بعض الاماكن
فريق قام بالتصوير في مدينه المعروفه الان
بقوسين يعني بما يسمى بانتهاكات وجرائم
الحرب التي قامت مع بعض القوات هناك في
حقوق في حق المدنيين قاموا بسجنهم في احدى
المصانع القديمه
ومنهم من تم ترحيله الى السجون في موسكو
الحال الان حسب القانون الدولي يصعب جدا
المطالبه بهؤلاء لانهم ليسوا جنود تعرفين
غادي جيدا انهم اذا كانوا جنود فهم يدخلن
في اطار سجناء الحرب لابد ان يعاملوا
بمعامله لائقه حسب اتفاقيه الجنب لكن بما
انهم مدنيين من الصعب جدا التواصل معهم
الان مازالت الامهات والزوجات والاخوات
تبكين يعني اولادهن
بشكل يومي بشكل يومي في محاوله لاسترجاع
هؤلاء المدنيين او هؤلاء الجنود على ما
اعتقد الان يتواصل تتواصل الجهات
الاوكرانيه مع العديد من الجهات الدوليه
من اجل على الاقل جمع قائمه عن الذين ما
زالوا على قيد الحياه اما الذين ماتوا فمن
الصعب جدا التعرف عليهم او الوصول اليهم
هذا ثاني تقرير سوف يتم عرضه في هذا
الاسبوع بمناسبه بعض الغزوه عشان عفوا على
غزو الغزو الروسي لاوكرانيا زميلي عبد
القادر شكرا
هي